Nói phân hôn bộ chứng quên trường các chơ mà anh đã bị dà với Iran,
Abraham, Joe Fagari,
các buồn nghĩ vậy xong đúng sau một âm mưu,
nhằm đổ lối cho Tayyuran về các của tấn công bằng mấy bài thương người lái sảy ra
tảm ạ tảm ạ sốt của xa trong khu dực.
Theo ông Joe Fagari, Washington và Tênna Vib đã sau chếp hiện tế mấy bài thương người lái
xa hết một bà sau của Iran và sử dụng một phín bản cả tiến,
được gọi là Lucas để tiến hành các của tấn công.
Sợ đó, quý trích nhạm trong Tayyuran,
ông Joe Sánng một tiêu của đồng thấy này là làm gát anh đi ngờ giữa Iran và các nước lắng diện,
từ đó, ngày xa gái đù vị Tayyuran cho một cạnh cánh thằng khu dực lâu thang.
Fia Iran khẳng định được lượng vũ trang này chỉ nhá mất các một tiêu liên qua nạn
nghĩ vậy xo real, đồng thời tiên bố luôn công khai thường nhận,
nhúng chính xe xong mình thực hiện.
Nếu bây giờ này đưa ra cho một cạnh cánh thằng khu dực và các báo cáo,
bây giờ phóng tới lừa và mấy bài thương người lái và thủy tìm đi ông mà Tayyuran đã phủ nhận.
Cống còn những báo cáo về các cuộc tấn công của đại dù quanh Mỹ tại mà đa
đi ông mà các quanh chức Iran cũng đã bắt bỏ.
Như tôi bố này đưa ra cho một cạnh cánh thằng khá tăng
sau các cuộc tấn công cuộc sự của Mỹ VICE R down nhà với Iran và của thằng hai.
Kéo theo các đồng đáp trả lắng tin lua và ua vệ trả nhiều điều điểm ở Trung đông.